[Music]
[Applause]
easter damian lillard joining us on the
program
did you guys get mellow anything for uh
the uh
milestone last night yeah we got him uh
a game up it seemed like you've been
collecting every game ball this year
but i'm i'm definitely gonna have a gift
for him uh when we get back to portland
for breaking that top ten i told him
last night that
i'm the kind of person that's kind of
like i just move on to the next thing i
guess i don't
do a good enough job of appreciating
stuff while it's happening
but uh top 10 is special you know and i
told him that
what is mellow like
mellow is when when we first got mellow
last season
i didn't know i didn't really know what
to expect
um because some people are you know such
a high status
and popularity and you know he's
legendary in the sport as well
so you just don't know what type of
character they they might have
and who they might be truly you know as
opposed to what you see on camera
and uh when he came around it was like
he laughed at everything easy going you
know just
down the earth it was it was the
complete opposite of everything that
people tried to make him out to be
and what you would expect is somebody
with with that type of status
um you know as a celebrity and as as a
basketball player
um but i'm i'm super comfortable with
them and i don't
and i don't really you know warm up to
people
like that you know i don't i don't
really get you know come close to people
like that and mellow isn't
great teammate a great person um
a fun person to be around and um
i've been really um surprised by you
know who he is as a person
and um you know my respect has only gone
up
you know since he's been on our team i
don't know if you saw the
performance turned in by uh westbrook
last night but
uh scottie brooks his coach said he
thinks
russell westbrook's the second greatest
point guard of all time
yeah i mean he he's always going to have
an argument for that you know i mean
it's it's going to be his fourth season
i saw that
you know he's averaging a triple double
which
regardless of you know if people say
he's
chasing stats or you know hunting stats
or whatever like
it takes a that takes a lot to be able
to do that even if you're trying your
best so
um you know i think westbrook gets a lot
of unnecessary uh
flack or you know hate or whatever you
want to call it but uh
his approach how hard he plays how
aggressive he is how much he cares
you know he's a good person off the
court
um he definitely has an argument for
that is he better than you
i don't think no point guard in the nba
is better than me
well magic's the best of all time right
i think that's that's consensus you know
a lot of people say that okay
where's steph curry on that list i think
staff would
you know if you it depends on what
you're going off of you know
the quality of the player like if they
was to just if you just line these two
guys up or
what has this person accomplished in
their career
and you know steph has two two mvps
a unanimous mvp back-to-back titles
three total titles
um you know the resume is there so i
think
if you ask 10 people you know seven of
them or eight of them would probably
come back and say you know steph is
right behind magic
and the way he's changed the game um
the excitement you know with his style
of play and i think he's changed the
game more than any other player game
when you think about everybody who steps
on the floor
you can be five five you can be five ten
you you don't have to be seven foot you
don't have to jump out of the gym
like steph gave everybody hope that they
could somehow do this
even though you know nobody's going to
be able to do quite like what he's done
but he does give you that
we can't be like mike you know we may
want to be like jordan
we feel like we can be like steph curry
yeah
yeah i mean usually when you got a nba
superstar
is somebody with you know great gifts
um you know god given things six six six
seven
super athletic um things that
you know if your parents don't have that
genetic
makeup like you can't be that and then
you have you know guys that
just work on it and you know guys who
just
they make themselves what what they
become and
i think that's what steph is is a
product of now obviously he's not five
five he's six foot three and
his dad played in the nba so it's there
are things there that you know give him
an advantage as well but
um a guy that's five nine or five ten
could
could follow what he does you know and
have a chance
is he a better shooter than you i think
steph was the greatest shooter all time
yeah
are you second
i think i'm top five
i think i'm i think i'm top five it's
been so it's been some great shooting
okay who else is in there though damon
okay so you and steph top five
who else i would have to like
it depends you know some guys are the
way i look at it some guys
shoot off pin downs you know some guys
are catching shoe
uh some guys don't take a lot of
attempts some guys don't take
tough attempts you know and i think
where i would put myself really high up
there is because i'm not a guy that gets
high quality
shots a lot of my shots are off the
dribble
contested um
from from deep range um like me and step
shoot a lot of
similar three-pointers and i feel like i
don't even get the
the clean looks that he gets because of
you know the way their offense is set up
he's you know sometimes he ends up wide
open because
of some of the actions that they in or
transition they'll scream for him
you know before the defense is set and
he's he's more open um
but i think when it comes to that um i'm
at the i'm top of the top you know i'm
right up there
he's uh damien lindlard he's the blazers
guard
where's your patience level with this
team
my team yeah you know make the playoffs
okay but
like win a championship like thank you
you know that's how greatness is defined
at at the end it's like how many
championships you got
you don't have those i would say this
like the
it's how greatness is defined by
i guess the world you know people will
say how many rings and how many of this
and how many that
and like i know my story you know i know
i had to scratch and claw and fight and
earn everything that i have so
um i i want to win a championship as bad
as anybody
um but like i won't
i won't view um
things like
what i've what i what i've done hasn't
been amazing
you know based off of what it took to
get here and what i put into what i have
accomplished
um you know so like i feel like what
i've done has been greatness
but do i want to accomplish the ultimate
that's what
that's what makes the situation um that
we've been in the last few years
frustrating
because you just want to you just wanted
to experience that you want to get to
the
to the mountaintop and be that last team
standing you know i think that's
that's where the frustration is um you
know and it's not like we just have the
worst days ever like we got we have a
great work environment we got
great people you know everybody cares
um but i'm i you know i've won
or we've won since my second year we've
been in the playoffs every year you know
we've
been in 3c twice we've been to the
western conference finals and
where i'm at in my career is like to get
to that
that next level is like you can't
continue to just be okay with oh we're
making the playoffs you know
um you're working hard and you know at
some point you got to just be like
it's time to go for it you know i want
to i want to experience that
championship level
um and that's where the frustration
comes in whereas when it's like you know
i want that you know are you in your
bathroom right now
no i'm actually sitting in the living
room of my um my hotel oh okay i was
wondering i got a stat for you
through six hundreds you thought i was
saying
i i did i was looking behind you it
looked like there was a toilet behind
it okay okay all right you got a nice
room there all right so now it's
official
you're not you're not on your toilet
like i had to prove myself right
it would have been a better story if you
were sitting on your toilet um
through 675 career games
carmelo had 16 777 points
through 675 career games you have 16
588 points
so he's only a couple of hundred points
ahead of you
when when he was uh at the same stage in
in your career
although mello had a total of four
assists
at that time through 675
oh he's going he gonna get it up no
question about it
if you throw it do you expect it back
if i throw it to mello yeah
i think with um oh you gotta be honest
i'm gonna be honest because you asked if
if i throw it do i expect it back
okay if it's somebody else who throws it
yeah like i think when you like
when you when you've scored at the level
that we've scored at
and you're playing with another player
who has as well
um you know i think his confidence and
his
his how comfortable he is throwing it
back to me is different
you know and when i throw so like with
that said when i throw it to him
i have confidence that there's a chance
it'll come back but i don't expect it to
because i know
i know a score is mine you know when he
gets it he like
yeah about the score you know so like
when i throw it i don't expect it but
i'm like
i i keep myself ready because i know
it's a chance that you know
he'll make the right play back to me
because of the trust you know he knows
that i'm a scorer at that level too
last time i talked to you you were
either having twins
or you had twins i think i was having
twins
okay yeah how's that how's that going
it's been busy it's been busy um i had a
boy and a girl so
you got to play zone defense right now
you and your wife right like he
man we i mean we figuring it out
obviously we got help i got a lot of
family in portland
nanny um
but it's it's definitely busy man you
know and having a girl
is also different it hits your heart
differently
oh she got i got three daughters she
gonna she gonna break
for you oh and and you know when they
get married i'm going to be a mess
i'm going to be an absolute mess you got
a lot of time but i'm i'm just telling
you
save your money
um if if you went to the playground and
you can have anybody
not on the blazers and you're going to
play two on two
who are you showing one one player yeah
you got one player it's a two on two
game
i'm showing up with kevin durant oh
okay i think that's pretty easy
i think you're winning that game but i'm
i'm not sure if lebron shows up with
steph
that's pretty good i'd watch that well i
think um
it would definitely be a great two on
two but is durant the best player in the
game
when healthy i think um him and lebron
are like
they're right there i think kd
katie healthy could very well be the
best player in the nba he's such a
match-up nightmare though i mean there's
there's just nobody i mean nobody nobody
can guard him
like if he's healthy he's shooting
threes off the dribble he's pulling up
off the dribble he's posting up you can
get to the rim
you can't block his shot he can hit like
the way he handles the ball
the way he moves at that size who are
you going to put on him like
i mean when healthy i think like at this
moment he could
very well be the best player in the
league
well it's great to catch up with you
sorry about the loss last night you got
the cavs i
i got you penciled in for 51 against the
cavs does that
sound okay hey man we'll see
i mean come on can you put up 50 for me
and that's not asking too much you got
how many how many i mean it's always a
possibility but
you got 12 50 point performances in your
career
that's not asking that much i mean do
one for your daughter okay
give her a 50. give her a 50. is there
is it
it's always a possibility but is
somebody going to get close to kobe's 81
yeah who
i think it would if somebody's gonna get
close to kobe's 81 i think it would be
between me steph
me steph
um
devin booker can really get hot
um i would say somebody on brooklyn but
it's
you know with all three of them being
out there is gonna be tough so i would
say
me steph devin booker
um is somebody that i'm missing
can clay clay clay could do it
and i would say who else bradley beal
i think brad could do it too but that's
i think
that's 81. i think it's
it's gonna take a crazy night but it's
it can happen
give me the team that you would do it
against like if you just save i can get
80
against that defense it would have to be
against a team with a
a bit that's not mobile
because they wouldn't be able to be up
as high like in my in pick and rolls and
stuff like that
i think i'll be like damn i think i
could get 10
against the pelicans
see the thing with the pelicans is they
they play hardest as hell it's just
it's just a lot of lapses you know it's
a lot of it's a lot of lapses like
like over the throughout the course of
the game but it's not it's not an easy
game
you know like lonzo ball plays good
defense he's
long he plays hard they got i mean
it's not a it's not a walk in the park i
know people put big games on them but
it's just it's just because
it's more so because of lapses than it
is because they just
you know eric bledsoe too like they not
it ain't no pushover you know it's not
an easy game out there
yeah but i think i could probably get a
bucket right like a defensive lap so i
could get a like
you leave me open from like 15 to 18.
bang it's down man
maybe i don't i don't know your skill
although man you know i i did research
homework on you
i just say you you check youtube youtube
you're
gonna see it it'll be people are still
talking about it
i'm gonna do my homework yeah do your
homework cause
i'd hate to you know all of a sudden i
see it on the court and we start
shooting you go oh whoa
okay somebody's got a little bit of game
here
hey it actually wouldn't surprise me all
right i appreciate that
but i wouldn't bring the kids out
because i don't want you to get
embarrassed in front of the kids you
know if all of a sudden i start lighting
it up you know because
i don't have no shame i don't have no
shame i'm up
i'm always ready for whatever the
outcome is going to be i love you
i love it uh good luck against the cavs
uh lakers then coming up after that
great to catch up with you
damn thanks for joining us all right
that's damian lillard of my blazers